if you are sat over here what would you
like to hear a freestyle rap about
none lovely stuff what what is it
I find intriguing
their wardrobe and the nuns wardrobe
choices okay cool the nuns wardrobe
choices if you are sat in this rectangle
from the front to the backwards like a
rapper
I I heard nothing of what you said but
is that obviously I just kicked you no
well yeah technically it was on the
stage so get the [ __ ] off
what
did you say sir
James Bond in Texas thank you very much
there's some real imagination going
there you can tell this is like you know
the early evening show because you know
you've had like one and a half drinks
and so you come up with sensible stuff
like that whereas later in the evening
it's just
titties titties rap about the titties
nuns wardrobes James Bond in Texas
middle of the room front to the back
what do you want Nirvana
um the the the 90s Grand band from
Seattle or the the concept of
enlightenment
the concept cool I can't see from the
light okay you're a brown lady so now I
just
if you were if you were a scraggly head
white boy I'd be like yeah okay Nirvana
also you you said it properly you were
like Nirvana
um Colin did you forget your glasses on
that that's very stupid
because I saw her at the corner I was
like why is Colin Quinn walking towards
the stage is this the whitest version of
Chris Rock and Will Smith going on did I
accidentally upset Colin Quinn but no
Colin couldn't wait he could have you
know he could have asked James to bring
them back he was like no I I need his
glasses now
um so I I as a man who wears glasses I I
understand the paint so Nirvana but you
said Nirvana because you pronounced it
properly but I'm gonna say Nirvana
because I prefer the what you what you
holding up no no I do need glasses but I
don't need a random person's glasses I
mean if you hand them to me I'll tell
you if they're my prescription they
won't be I'm legally quite blind these
are these are so light these lenses are
so thin I mean I can unless you're these
are so dirty as well that is ridiculous
oh you understand Enlightenment but not
translucency [ __ ] clean it up what is
this
[Laughter]
um oh you're you're weird your eyes are
you have you have more than just short
sightedness right there's like extra
[ __ ] in there as well
it's it's actually you you probably do
have money because those are very light
lenses for how severe that prescription
is
a party trick of mine this is how fun I
am used to be I'll take people's glasses
and tell them their prescription I could
usually get within 0.5 with that no I
don't know what's wrong with your eyes
off
okay Nirvana nuns wardrobe James Bond in
Texas
um this next two need to be quick so
this section over here which I'll rap
out
there were two you said
jail and you said psychology cool
psychology jail and yeah you sometimes
when you combine them it makes them
better that has just made both of those
one [ __ ] and the final section over here
watching like McDonald's
Donald oh McDonald's great cool not the
and what did you say
Jeremy are you suggesting suggestions
okay cool
you're thinking about emotes today cool
as in as in the ring of water around a
fortification culprit well no because it
could also be m-o-t-e like a moat like a
moat of dust like a tiny it's it's a
word it is it's a speck it's another
word for a speck or a particle I'm
hello it is why are you shaking your
head
you just learned that was a word yeah
you're educational and entertaining
mainly the former right
let's do this
if we if
we drop a drop a beat and we can go
faster than we did last night I think
because I I think
so
[Applause]
wardrobe Texas
this is the worst rhyming ever this is
terrible psychology jail and a motor
around McDonald's
[Music]
McDonald's asking for fries from the
server they asked me a question flip it
back how the [ __ ] did you get in here
how did you attack I didn't realize this
McDonald's is fortified I walk in extra
large that's my real size I feel happy
when I rap at the counter you gotta
counter attack there's an amount of
people outside with the trebuchet
slingshots coming my way so I say we
need to build a river a portion of a sea
why right now this McDonald's Under
Siege people coming in they want the
Happy Meal toy so I get the oil and I
avoid start burning out fire and arrows
from the murder slits if you've never
seen a mo if you've never heard of it is
slightly confusing the water we use it
put it around the building we're
cruising down Heaven way having such fun
see the religious lady I'm shouting out
nuns none yeah on the left-hand side oh
they've gone out guys white and black
sister
and sisters dawned in monochrome quite
fashionable the way that they walked
they Sway and they talk dressed like
they're in New York because we're
wearing all black a little bit of white
monks hide and they give them a fright
like jumping out but the sister
Elizabeth they say calm down monks we're
sick of this moving on this part will
fail there's nothing entertaining about
psychology jail inherently you could see
Sigmund Freud did the hard time there
cause he couldn't avoided he says I'm so
frustrated I've got a dumb person for my
cell mate it's just some guy doing five
to eight says Sigmund Freud you think
you're so great technically he's a
psychiatrist not a psychologist
apologies got it mixed up you're like
okay Chris it doesn't rise going on to
death row psychology student yeah you
guys know ah how do I honor this how do
I conceive of being locked down it's
[ __ ] I'm in solitary confinement no Real
Deals when I wanna transcend how does it
feel I wanna feel Superior it to any
other so I start reading the teachings
of the Buddha people say he's a religion
is frightening but I find his writings
are rather enlightening it's lovely yeah
the British guy charms you crying on
your glasses but Siddhartha katama was
his name but he was the prince have a
lot people love it yeah you know he took
the middle path but I'm going there up
to the Pacific Northwest Kurt Cobain
Dave brought Chris not facelic they did
it best they were walking now they're on
the stage never mind 1991 this is great
I've never had one Indian lady standing
saying this incredible I'm understanding
but don't worry usually across the pond
double 07 so pleasant Mr James wants
he'd be like hella money Penny I respect
you but imagine if James Bond was in
Texas he'd be walking around he'd be
shooting where you from James [ __ ]
Houston I'm gonna shoot orange blow fell
down who am I gonna do it for H-Town oh
yeah I'm gonna shoot the white hat gonna
ah yeah Texas I'm feeling the thrill
double 07 a real license to Kill
[Applause]